[Music]  all we want to do is help our patients  but what they don't teach you some  medical schools there are so many ways  to do harm you didn't order me I didn't  appendectomy  you need to consider a change before you  kill any more patients you watch  yourself correct  everything you thought you knew about  medicine is wrong you do whatever I tell  you no questions asked I need a new  resident you got Conrad yes I did  watch and learn all the rules that you  follow will break  this is just isn't what I imagined if it  were easy everyone would be a doctor  because this is the best job in the  world despite everything becoming twenty  patients no backup  what do you mean no pack don't page me  if there's a serious problem but  remember that's a sign of weakness don't  let him kill anyone I'll do my best  you